prince harry is not a fan of the first
amendment in america the royal taking
issue with the paparazzi
and the quote feeding frenzy he
experienced when he arrived in los
angeles with his wife
meghan markle i don't want to start
sort of going down the first amendment
group because that's a huge subject and
one of which i don't understand is i've
only been in a short period of time but
you can find a loophole in anything
and you can capitalize or exploit what's
not
said rather than uphold what is said
there's so much i want to say about the
first amendment
don't understand it but it is bonkers oh
my god
so jesse do you think he has some uh
anger issues with the press uh
and maybe understandably i mean his
mother absolutely was fleeing the
paparazzi when she died right
well if he thinks the first amendment's
bonkers waiting he hears about the
second one
this guy complains about the press more
than he
more than donald trump is he even really
a member of the royal family i didn't
think royals were allowed to complain no
one else in his family
complains about anything except the
climate i guess
why is he talking so much keep it inside
a little bit
see a shrink don't do every interview
he's like fouchy
he did a dax shepard podcast a prince
did a podcast
i mean he was just on oprah you don't
you can say no to dak
shepherd's podcast my god and now he
says like oh we didn't really learn that
much about the first amendment in school
i mean we learned about great britain we
go over there
we play along and we bow and do the
whole thing
he never learned about the revolutionary
war they never taught that at eaton i'm
going to send them a copy of killing
england one
[Laughter]
so greg we do have limits though you
can't slander and libel people right so
is he right in that regard uh we can
happens every day i don't know if i can
do anything better than what uh
jesse just said but this guy claims that
he hates the press and paparazzi
uh so i know what i'll do i'll move to
hollywood with a fame hungry actress
so that is not fleeing paparazzi he
knows they know exactly what they're
doing
um and and uh um he kind of looked
i think he was described to his defense
i think he's describing the first
amendment as
an oddity that is unique to america the
same way we look at british teeth
[Laughter]
so dana why do we care well he's making
us care because he's
like if you're a british person i live
with one and you come to the country
and then you say like i don't understand
this whole first second amendment thing
i don't understand this whole freedom
thing
um that basically means like you really
don't get it at all and if you're going
on a podcast
or oprah winfrey and you start the
sentence with i really don't want to go
down the road of talking about the first
amendment because i really don't know
enough about it you can stop there
right you have to say anything else but
let me give you an example prince
um for example under our first amendment
the duchess
can slander an entire royal family with
racism
yes exactly and guess what there's no
consequences for that
right yes i mean and everybody in malibu
and all the young people that want to
think that oh wow that was just so brave
that was so great
that's one of the things that the first
amendment can provide
yeah it protects now dagen when you look
at this do you think that we
defer and protect the royal family
versus deferring to harry and megan
um i don't what i
what i i look at harry
and i think the only thing that he can
say that's positive
is i'm not as odious as prince andrew
he's the kind of guy you tell to bring
some lattes over
if he's stopping by and he shows up with
a roll of masking tape and a pomegranate
he's completely useless but he is
capable of
you know whinging on oprah winfrey with
his wife and
exercising that first amendment like an
olympic triathlete
well done
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else